ah
so
just wait and uh
wait to confirm that i'm coming through
that people are seeing me and hearing me
all right
and uh we'll go from there
i uh
uh
sorry i watched the um
the she-hulk teaser
right before coming on i made the
decision that i didn't have the time or
the energy to do a reaction video to it
um
i'm really torn on it because
it's like it's taking the angle and it's
doing the character the way i would want
them to
but the effects look real bad
like really bad
like mid-2000s bad
like it
it looks more fitting to be next to eric
bonner's hulk bad
and
ah
oh
boy
i'm uh
uh i i'm i'm not um
thrilled by how prominent it looks like
it's gonna be used either it would have
been one thing if it was just a couple
of glimpses or it hinted that like they
were gonna use it sparingly but we see
her in multiple settings multiple
lighting setups multiple outfits
and you know full on as she hulk and
oh
it does not look good
uh it's coming out in august
which means um
some people
uh are saying oh well they have time to
clean up the effect i don't think they
do
and i mean if they put it in the trailer
they think it's good to go
they wouldn't have put it in the trailer
if they didn't think it was something
worth seeing
that doesn't work as a defense for me
like
i'm not gonna say unfinished effects
never show up in trailers but you don't
prominently feature unfinished effects
because you blow the first impression
so
[Music]
that's uh
that was real disappointing
then again we got a sonic trailer well
yeah but again
that was intended to be the finished
effect
and i would point out they had more than
just three months for that from when the
first teaser hit
um
and they also badly crunched their
effects team so you know also screw them
so
sonic had more time than this
and uh also
the effect was simpler
for sonic because it didn't have to look
realistic
sonic was cartoonish he was supposed to
be cartoonish they bungled by trying to
go for realism
because he doesn't have to look
all that real quote unquote they had a
lot of leeway with the redesign
she-hulk is supposed to look real in
this world
that's not something you can
redo
in months
it's just
not
anyways
so yeah i um
i'm actually not sure
off the top of my head at least that i
have that much to talk about doctor who
off top my head
um i am sure that it's going to be the
dominant topic
of the day though i have no doubt it's
what's going to be
mainly in the chat um it's probably
what'll come up with the super chats i
suppose i should explain how that works
oh hey jesse i didn't see you come in
uh i didn't say hi to it folks carowind
uh pirates
gozer ms wicked wolf adrenaline
cappuccino
aaron geek filter all sorts of folks
here um so yes um for anyone joining the
stream for the first time way this works
is i do attempt
to keep up with the chat
i make no promises the only there's only
two things that guarantee that i will
see your
comments
and read them and respond to them
one is making use of the super chats
which will also get you a heart from me
the other is if you are a patreon
supporter
um you can go to the council of geeks
patreon and go to the dedicated channel
to ask questions to be dealt with during
the live stream i'll deal with those
later that's the uh the discord for the
patreon supporters
anyway and we've got our first one in
supreme omega thank you so much do you
fear the day when doctor who gets
cancelled and will go on an indefinite
hiatus like uh just like it happened
back in the late 80s at the end of the
seventh doctor era i
oh so
the way you worded the question there's
two different ways i can take it i'll
try and tackle both uh the first is
am i afraid that it will happen
no
because we live in an era where you
don't put
massive sprawling spin-off-able
multimedia franchises on hiatus
you just don't that's not how that's not
how the world works anymore so there's
that but even if it were to happen it
would not bother me so much now granted
i wasn't following dr who during the
wilderness years but
we know doctor who can and will survive
it whether it gets revived or not
big finish still exists
novels comics conventions fans like
doctor who even if the show stopped
wouldn't go away in terms of
you know meaningful engagement with the
franchise so while i don't want it to
get cancelled or go on on an indefinite
hiatus i am neither afraid that it will
happen nor afraid of it if and when it
does
i'll be a little bummed out but not
afraid
uh would you ever pick up inside number
nine again we're halfway through another
series right now no
nope
nope that uh that was probably top of
the list
um
for uh
a series that
i was completely put off it by the fans
for folks who don't know i did reviews
episode by episode reviews of the first
series of insight number nine and i
liked it for the most part but i wasn't
overwhelmingly praising of it and
apparently i was critical of like a
golden child episode of the first series
and
i got some of the most concentrated
vitriol that i have gotten from any
fandom
just basically calling me
all kinds of crap
mostly an idiot because i dared to
criticize it and frankly i don't care if
it's any good
if that's the kind of people who enjoy
it i don't want to take part i kind of
have the same feeling about rick and
morty if i'm being completely honest
the fandom turns me off so much that i'm
like i
don't
want to like
something that people who behave like
you enjoy and that's not me saying
anyone who enjoys inside number nine or
rick and morty are jerks but i'm saying
my interactions with the fandom
no
no that that put me off
really bad
really bad
uh it's kind of unique in that way i'm
not sure that's happened to me otherwise
i've had things that i like where i'm
like i will choose to not engage with
the fandom um and just enjoy this on my
own which i actually do with a lot of
things despite this being my job i
actually don't actively engage with the
doctor who fandom outside of the gallery
one convention all that much
um
but anyways
i wonder if the inside number nine fans
hold it as that sort of untouchable
place because it's intelligent possibly
whatever
uh what is inside number nine uh insight
number nine is a british anthology show
it's
it's a little like i've seen people
compare it to black mirror which is
probably an overstatement in terms of
the level of darkness of it but it is
kind of dark
so i i i get that there is a
lack of other points of comparison
have you seen love death and robots yes
yes i did a review of the first season i
didn't do a review of the second season
because i didn't have enough thoughts on
it and i saw the trailer for the third
season and saw way too dang much ultra
realistic cgi that i look at and go if
it's gonna look this good
uh good quote unquote this realistic
just film live action actors what is the
point how is this animation like that
that just as a visual aesthetic for uh
animation just annoys me on principle
i just don't i just don't like it
i never have
um
so
i'm i'm very
i'm very mixed i like i like um
love death and robots in theory and in
principle i like that it exists
it uh
frequently does not really work very
well for me though
uh strum dynasty thank you very much for
the super chat this just in william
hartnell to play 14th doctor to
regenerating to david tennant to
regenerating to shootie godzilla oh boy
i know this stuff is gonna start
leaking in
um
i don't know how much energy i have to
engage with the
uh with the
rumor mill that and what it's spinning
um since
the last video i made
just because people are getting
really like aggressively
insistent
about their pet theories
um
and it's the kind of thing that like
there's a reason that
my general standard is
um
i don't talk about rumors
if it's not official i don't talk about
it i kind of made an exception with that
second video about the uh the upcoming
special
because like we had some truly we had
some actual confirmed stuff
in terms of um yasmine finney
and then we had stuff that you know
people were filmed on
on a shooting location so
it wasn't a uh a rumor sorry give me one
second
sorry i thought i heard something
uh oh bookworm of the fandoms thank you
kindly thank you very very much uh was
thinking since you published a few from
what i've read very good books thank you
do you have any advice for editing a
story mine is currently 47 pages and
growing uh don't worry about editing
until you have a finished draft
that's the first thing one one of the
classic mistakes of amateur writers and
this is something that i know i did
early on when i was first trying to
write uh my novel
um is
you
you hit a point where you start going
back and refining and revising what
you've already written instead of moving
ahead
don't even think about editing until you
have a finished draft and i know part of
you is going to be tempted because
you're like you're going to get on a
roll you're going to write you're going
to think wait does this even fit what i
already wrote you know did i just
contradict myself does this float don't
worry about it finish the draft
the editing phases for catching the
mistakes
don't worry about it until you have the
finished draft that is the main thing
that i would advise folks on
have you seen the storyline for the
unmade 30th anniversary special lost in
the dark dimension because it seems that
russell might be doing his own version
of that with the 60th i have not i know
nothing about it and i would kindly ask
you not to give me details if that is at
all likely
have i seen the new how owl house up to
uh at least up to hollow mind i've seen
i've seen up through whatever is the
most recent episode that is on disney
plus
i don't remember what the name of it was
yes i'm aware they're making legally
blonde three ms wicked wolf
fine
i don't know why you expect me to have
an opinion on that uh supreme omega
thank you again
does every surrealized tv show need a
defined plan no
it's um
it's it's very
easy to over plan a series
because
look things are gonna happen that you
aren't
expecting
things are just not gonna go your way
actors will become
unavailable uh a certain thing that
you'd planned on seeding won't go over
well with the audience maybe you'll have
to change that plan a character you
intended as a brief appearance gets
really popular you you bring them in so
like for serialized
tv
you should have a plan
you should have a sense of here's where
i'm starting here's where i'm trying to
get to but it should not be rigid it
needs to be flexible because tv needs to
be able to to change and shift as it's
being made that's the nature of
long-form storytelling you have to be
willing to roll with however it ends up
going
and i think that's the thing when people
say you know this tv show was planned
from the beginning i'm like
planned outline or planned rigid because
planned rigid it probably wasn't very
good unless it's a limited series like
miniseries that's fine like
you know anything any
anything that you're gonna shoot the
entirety of before a single episode of
it airs
yes you should have a complete plan for
obviously
but um anything that it it
uh the the
opening is there for the story to be
impacted by the response of the audience
you better have some flexibility going
on
i think a series needs more
of a rule book an initial loose a to z i
mean it also depends on how you're
selling it
um so like one of the reasons that
uh lost kind of gets its butt kicked in
this category
is people complain that you know they
didn't
uh have
um
they didn't have everything worked out
and that's what's wrong with the show
that's not really what's wrong with the
show what's wrong with the show was it
was marketed and sold and presented as
if
everything had an answer but that was
literally never the case so i actually
think lost
its failures were more a failure of
marketing clashing with the reality than
what the creative process was
uh the al house episode i'm talking
about is the one where loose and 100 go
into bellows is mine i did see that one
yes i had called that twist about 10
episodes previous
um but yes i did
am i excited for jody whitaker's final
episode i
don't
no
like it feels very strange to think that
um jodie whittaker still has her last
episode coming up because
the entire conversation has shifted to
nearly everything other than
that
so
which i feel bad about
i want to enjoy it but i've said that
about pretty much every whitaker episode
i've ever seen i want to like them i
frequently have not
so
you know
i heard with lost that it was supposed
to be three seasons and because of its
popular studio the studio made abrams
extended unnecessarily i hadn't heard
that for lost i know that was the case
for supernatural because that was
planned as five seasons
lost was already a mess because season
three happened i think it was three it
was either three or two i think it was
three happened during the writers strike
so that like their
whatever was going on got borked anyways
uh would i rather watch a moffett or an
rtd whitaker episode
i don't know
dead
neither
like i don't
i don't
know
i
that's the kind of hypothetical i'm just
really i'm not a good person to ask my
brain
rejects the premise of the question
because my brain goes well that's never
going to happen so why should i have an
opinion on it at all and then i can't
form one uh that thank you jesse it was
season three of lost that happened
during the writers strike
thank you very much
uh would you be mad if would i be mad if
gotham was canon
i know it never will be just curious
why
why would i be mad at gotham being canon
i like gotham
i'm confused by the question
i will defend lost to the death uh you
you and my partner both jessie although
she won't defend all of it she will
defend the uh the ending though would
you like the idea of a multi-doctor
special in march 2025 to mark the 20th
anniversary of the show's return okay
look
pick an anniversary and stick to it it's
going to start turning into like um
those you know that high school couple
like it's our six week anniversary like
dad
stop pick one
it's annual stick with that
i don't know why but whenever i hear rtd
i immediately think of r2d2 well what's
really confusing is i've seen people
already preemptively calling this new
era of him taking over the show again as
rtd2
which yeah that one sets off the r2d2
thing for me too
uh it kind of feels like everyone is
done with the 13-hour big finish are
taking dwana martin everyone else
has moved on to our rtd2 there it is
right there um yeah that kind of does
it does feel like the case i i think
honestly
i think uh
excuse me i think the issue is more
how deeply lackluster
legend of the sea devils was
because
if it had been good
i think people would be
excited for last episode but it was
so bland
that i think everyone just went oh
this is what we can
expect with the end of this era
okay
and i i feel bad about that but like i
really do think that
legend of the sea devil sucked the
energy
that was left
i still hope the centenary special is
good
but
we'll see
have to admit rtd2 is a pretty clever
name that's is it
it's just the dude's initials with the
two slept on the end
clever to me is something that
isn't obvious
so what do you think of the newest batch
of owl house episodes they're good
they're good i enjoy i like the owl
house i enjoy them
my kid loves them
uh
oh
excuse me
i haven't watched see devils
disappointed to hear that a pirate
episode was lackluster it's yeah
the thing is some people really over
blew it like with it being oh it's this
terrible horrible that like it's
it's not it's too
bland to get worked up about which is a
different kind of disappointment
jesse jenner likes strange new worlds do
i i have not seen it
i also haven't seen discovery
or
anything of lower decks past the first
episode or
progeny or
um
the second season of a card so like i'm
i'm not a person to be uh to be asking
about star trek
i have a kid yes sophia i have a kid
uh i get oh geez i hadn't looked at the
viewer number so i'm assuming there must
be a fair number of folks here who don't
normally stop in so yes yes i do indeed
have a child
um i'd love to see jody get redeemed in
big finish she deserves better writing
i would like that too but i mean if she
wants to take a break first
i get it
uh where did i get this water bottle
this uh was sent to me to my p.o box
uh i forget by whom
because i have a memory like a sieve but
that's that's where that comes from
i'm quite fond of it
uh
so here's my idea from last week
go to a bookstore or library pick a 200
page plus book that you've never heard
of and review the last half of it you
can
you can't read the blurbs either
that's a
an interesting quirky project
not sure it's something that i could
engage with but it's interesting
the one thing i want to know is how the
idea of the centenary is
shoehorned into the plot ah
who knows
no uh loris i have not i haven't had the
free time to listen to doctor who
redacted um because i i have no free
time at all
i am
behind on a video for the vera wild
channel that i had hoped to have out
last month i'll be lucky if i can have
it out this month
um
and i'm trying to get my audiobook
edited and
i
don't
have the time
i just don't
which is frustrating
uh who would you say is the most bland
or unnecessary doctor who villain well
i've got to assume you mean recurring
because if we're going with one-offs
um like and everything's up for grabs i
just there's just too many options to be
blunt about it
um
i mean i never liked the ronnie
that's sort of the easy uh
pass
but uh
i don't know
i th well if we're going unnecessary i
guess you'd have to go one off because
there's a number of episodes oddly a
fair number of them written by chris
chibdell where um
the villains or the monsters don't need
to be there and they add nothing to the
proceedings i think that's true of the
saranga conundrum i think that's true of
42 um i think that's
not 100 but it's it
i think demons of the punjab could have
not had the aliens and it would have
been fine um it yeah
that does happen unfortunately
your curblam view is the best thing i've
heard on the episode finally added
something new to the conversation it's
funny to me that that it was even a new
perspective
because like i hadn't rewatched it since
it aired and so i'd seen a lot of the
criticisms that had come out
um
towards it and the time since
and i understood them but i hadn't like
gone back and watched it for myself and
then i do that and i watch that episode
and i realize
everybody's missing the point including
the episode itself
wait a minute what
likes are 69 nice
uh
that is nice we'll see how long it lasts
the power of three would be a favor if
it wasn't for the last third yeah the
that was actually a really good episode
up until the tail end
how would you feel about anime doctor
who content i feel the monsters have
some real potential ah
i'm not against it but for some reason
just the general idea doesn't grab me
um
i have a hard time knowing why
but
i don't know
i think the thing is
i need to see doctor who animated in a
style other than how it's been animated
up to this point i need to see a
completely fresh visual take on a doctor
who animated series then maybe i could
have an opinion because right now all i
can think of are
the recreation animations which are fine
for what they are but like i don't need
more of that
on a scale of one to ten how cross are
you at rtd for buggering up your
schedule
ah
four
which probably sounds low but you you
don't want to see me higher than a six
i really thought nightmare and silver
should have been a two-parter well yeah
yeah nightmare and silver has way
way too much going on
if they made a doctor who anime would
you watch it ah again i feel like i'd
have to see like a concept trailer at
the very least
because my god instinct is
out of morbid curiosity but i don't
think i get excited for it
i wish the bbc got someone better to
animate the lost episodes like i'm not
saying i need them to hire studio
madhouse but at least something better
no i see the animation style for the
lost episode i actually do think
um
was the best style to go for like you
can debate over you know some
looking better than others but i think
that was the correct style if what
you're doing is trying to recreate
missing episodes
um but if you're but like to me the idea
of a doctor who animated series meanings
means we're not trying to recreate or
slot in with existing footage or
telesnaps or audio or whatever we're
doing something clean and then yeah you
better have a
better and more
animated style than that
supreme omega
here we go thoughts on soups silver age
stuff like crypto candor supergirl the
legion his time is super boy do you feel
they should be more important i don't
have a particular investment in the
silver age one way or the other i will
say um
respect to anyone who uh who enjoys them
and like wants to work here's here's my
thing
ultimately me personally i don't care
but i also don't think that even if you
want to do something more serious with
superman i don't think it's necessary to
run away from that and act like none of
it ever existed and be afraid of it and
act like it damages the
the nobility of superman the superman's
a goofy character but he can be used to
tell great stories he can be used to
tell silly stories and you don't have to
pretend that one or the other side of
that coin doesn't exist
did i see the cg on she-hulk
unfortunately i did i kind of opened
talking about that
what are my thoughts on the smurfs
i have none
i didn't watch the smurfs
have i ever watched wrestling
um
early 90s i did
a little
very little
um
i mean i liked the undertaker at the
time
i was 10.
um
but
you know
other than that
i don't really have too much to say
about that
are you gonna make a video on the newest
episodes of owl house um
i don't know
i don't know if i have time to make a
video
on it as i said like i'm i'm
i am
deeply
buried
uh in work
right now
i honestly don't think i have time in
addition to the fact that i'd probably
have to
re-watch most of season two to gather my
thoughts again
because right now the entire season is
pretty much bled together but it's also
probably bleeding together with some
stuff from season one
and
i definitely don't have time for that
like i feel bad
saying that
um
[Music]
you know because it's great that people
wanna wanna hear
um
my opinions
and i don't like saying i don't have
time but i
i don't
i just i don't
really love some alternate genre takes
on doctor who i mean fully diving into
it raimi horror with horrifying awesome
blues brooklyn nine-nine sitcom with
unit
i'd like to see some
things branch out a little bit more
um as well
honestly not necessarily this full
series on an episode by episode basis
honestly
thoughts on wb's multiverses
i have no clue what that is so i have
none
so it's still animation to fit something
else that's already recorded but would
you be interested in some big finished
stories were ever officially animated
absolutely not
never
they were made to be audio experiences
they are masterful audio experiences
the good ones are at any rate they're no
absolutely not i see no benefit and i
think it is
um
it is an undermining of the original
work because it implies that it needs
visuals and it doesn't
i have a philosophical objection to that
concept the same way that i have a
philosophical objection to making
live-action remakes of animated films i
feel like its very existence undercuts
the value of the original because it
implies that the original was somehow
incomplete or
somehow not definitive
which i reject
speaking of wrestling a recent tv screen
uh tv screening of the first spider-man
film cut out the mildly homophobic taunt
that peter said to bone saw oh
i mean that's probably for the best
that's
that said i know like channel pop got a
lot of mileage out of uh
out of making fun of that line so i have
a i have a little bit of a soft spot for
it because of that if nothing else am i
aware of eurovision i am in fact aware
that it is a thing
and i know what subwoofer is
that's all i've got
well i mean i know what subwoofer is to
the scent that anybody knows what the
heck subwoofer is but that's all i've
got
do you think hootie's voice was
partially inspired by mr bill from snl
i mean potentially
i don't know why you think hootie was
based on mr bill
hootie's an everlasting demon embedded
in a house i've been here longer than mr
bill
uh
sub woofer was banging subwoofer
uh
it was trying very hard to be the new
um
what does the fox say
and that transparent goal accepted
yeah it was fun
oh i knew somebody was going to ask this
why do you think david tennant has
jody's tardis during filming of the 60th
anniversary feels like a direct
continuation from the centenary or an
alternate doctor david also has a new
costume
i don't know
i don't know why any of it um i know a
lot of people are using the fact that
the tardis model seen on filming set
being the one that
whittaker made use of as uh definitive
proof of their prevalent theory that
whitaker is going to regenerate into
tenant and then tenant into gatwa which
i
i reject not because i think it's
impossible
but because i hate that idea
so much oh
thank you carowind uh john i forgot to
give you a heart for the super chat
thank you thank you carowind thank you
for that but yeah i just uh i am i
um
[Music]
i just think it's such a terrible idea i
can't engage with it and i've kind of
mentioned before
that i'm not a good person for
um
storyline predictions because my brain
just really doesn't work that way
do i prefer marfit or
marfit
moffett or rtd is show runner
overall
i think
moffat had for me higher highlights but
i think in terms of a general approach i
think davies um
had a better overall approach as a
showrunner
i think as a writer moffett
his best stuff is better than davies
best stuff
um but moffat's worst stuff is also far
worse
than
davies's worst stuff so you know uh it's
it's a mix i'm sorry getting a text give
me a second
uh
okay
that can wait
uh
uh thomas scott thank you for the um
super chat i can i can think i don't my
brain is stalling out today um thinking
we will get individual
10 to 12 episodes
in 2023 i don't know like
i'm i'm honestly
gonna be really curious
as to how many episodes
um
how many episodes we get
for series 14
because i would like
bbc
to grant more episodes to doctor who
rather than keep cutting them the way
they had
um
[Music]
but
like i would i would like to see it i
would honestly like to see it go back up
to 13 episodes but i'll take 10. um
but i am actually legitimately nervous
about that
uh until
we uh until we actually get official
word
acknowledging your backed up schedule do
you have any interest in amphibian now
that it's over i need to wait for it to
hit uh disney plus
so
i
unt and until that happens
ah
we rewatched midnight i
uh hoped the russell that saved that for
the end because he was worried it was
too out there is the russell we have now
i mean russell has
just evolved as a writer in general
since his time on who and i am very
curious to see how he comes at things
differently which i've said before
i wouldn't want him to waste a
regeneration on a 10 close because he
did that already
uh i'd like it more if 10 and 12 helped
gotchu's dock
i get on his feet post region i mean
like i don't have a story preference in
mind
um
i like davis better as much as rose and
ten could annoy me at times the most
important girl
pissed me all the way off
like
i don't
deeply dislike rose
but i feel like amy was a refinement of
rose and ditched most of the qualities
about her that i didn't like so
if you're if you're gonna compare those
two i'm gonna prefer amy certainly
speaking of amphibia i hope uh they got
rid of that character mr x oh i have no
idea if that's gonna show up again like
it
it is what it is i'm not gonna hold it
against the show
so you know what can you do
new subscriber here oh well welcome
aboard jonathan
yeah it's funny how doctor who is the
least exciting thing russell has written
in in terms of
excitement yeah i
russell has just gone on to have a
really
interesting uh
and nuanced
body of work since leaving doctor ah
crap speaking of things i don't have the
time for
freaking uh
time traveler's wife
started airing sunday i haven't watched
that
i should really
really try to because if i
if i don't get to the first episode by
the time the second one airs that's
basically a done deal and i who knows
when i'll get to it
have you re-watched uh moffat's comic
release special
time i always thought uh
there was deep misogyny running through
the entire moffat arrow i haven't
rewatched those shorts in a very long
time
i
so i'm trying to
figure out
how
why do i want to open this can of worms
i think
that
moffitt
has an awful lot
of unfortunate
unconscious
tropes and traits that he um slips into
when writing his female characters
i
don't believe
any of it's intentional which is not to
forgive it
unintentional harm is still harm
but i see the way that people talk about
some of the more probably problematic
elements of his writing or some of the
more unfortunate patterns in his writing
particularly when it comes to female
characters
and i see a lot of presumption of um
of intent and malice
towards him which
i don't
i don't see in the man's work at all
i think he
he could stand to be more introspective
and be more aware of his own um
his own foibles
but i don't think he does any of the
things he does out of malice and
honestly
here's where i really have to be careful
i say this i actually like a lot of his
female characters i think the bigger
problem with him
is his tendency to write
the these
same sort of
collection of traits into nearly every
prominent female character he writes
and you know the whole
sort of femme fatale angle the
mysterious angle
um you know which we saw in everything
from
clara to river song to missy to um over
in sherlock with um irene adler
you know it just comes up a lot and it's
not
great but i think it's it's worse for
its repetition because some of these
characters i actually like
but they are undoubtedly part of a
pattern that he overuses and does not
seem to be aware of some of the issues
with these patterns that he dips into
time traveler's wife is doctor who
fanfic fight me
uh
if the rumors not to be true uh then we
just know that the centenary special
will end with another what
what
what moment oh we'll see
uh
yeah he does coupling over and over and
that already had enough series and i
like i do like coupling as well i'm not
sure coupling is aged especially well
i think it's funny
i'm not recommending anybody who hasn't
already seen it go out and watch it but
i like coupling
sorry
uh
i always thought rotd had a similar
problem with writing mothers really
poorly um
hadn't thought about that i mean because
like the only prominent mothers i could
think off on my head in his era were
donna's mother and rose's mother and i
don't really care for either of them but
their issues are pretty dissimilar
i mean if you just mean the
general idea of like not great mothers i
mean
maybe but i hesitate to call
two instances a pattern
i like to have three
um before i
before i assume that
coupling it was funny at the time i mean
i i still laugh but then again i still
laugh at early red dwarf some of which i
probably shouldn't laugh at so
you know
from what i've seen rtd writes women
very desexualized whereas moff writes
women incredibly over sexualized i say
that frequently happens i do also think
people overstate how many times he does
he does do it too much like if we're if
we're going through um
you know
moffat's
over-sexualized overly mysterious femme
fatale mold
there's a lot of people in there
um
amy is
i don't think amy is deeply over
sexualized but her jump her trying to
jump the doctor isn't great
but i do think that clara falls into
this river falls into this missy falls
into this irene adler falls into this
but there are also exceptions
bill is almost like an anti-moffat
female character
and i love her for that
excuse me that's not to say that you
know the existence of bill cancels out
everything else i'm just saying you know
that wasn't all he wrote he did
overwrite that though
what is the best complaining accent uh
the one that springs to mind is the one
with the phone calls that is a good one
i remember the first coupling episode i
saw which i sell the soft spot for is
the one that um
it visualizes
um
patrick trying to leave
for the night and go back to his own
apartment
to sleep instead of staying and sleeping
with her in her bed
as a game of chess
i like that one
uh discord yes okay uh so i'm gonna pop
over to the council of geeks discord
really quick and address any questions
that are there reminder here that uh the
council of geeks discord is a patreon
exclusive perk so you can support the
patreon to get access to that so i'm
just gonna pop over there real quick
let's see question i don't think you
have ever done this
um but have you ever wanted to address
the content that other um
youtube creators
um talking about doctor who do because
of their blatant prejudices
uh some people do call it out
i'm not sure it's a good idea yet at the
same time i think people need to be
called out okay
so one thing i'm not going to do is i'm
not going to name names and i'm not
going to name channels if you know the
kind of channel that i'm referring to
then you don't need me to tell you
anyway and if you don't know then
let me spare you your innocence
but
i
don't have
a particularly
uh deep use
of call out culture
for someone who is not ashamed of the
thing you're calling them out for
i think whatever value there is in call
out culture which i'm going to use
instead of cancel because
boy has that term
turned into a whole other conversation
uh
i think the value that there is to be
had in that
is in bringing attention
to the
actions or statements
or beliefs
of
people that
what they are like is either unknown to
people who otherwise support them
or who maybe these people don't even
realize that they stepped in it
now i think there are better and worse
ways to go about that but there's some
value in that
i don't think there's a lot of value in
sinking very much of your time calling
out people who have absolutely no shame
and do not think there is anything wrong
with what they're doing now
to
uh head off another thing at the past
that does not mean ignore them
that doesn't mean pretend like they
don't exist because as much as we may
not want them to
these people are a part of the doctor
who fandom
they're not separate from it they are a
part well
some of them are because it is actually
a documented thing i don't know if with
doctor who specifically but it is
actually a documented thing of um
far-right extremists integrating geek
spaces on purpose to inject far-right
rhetoric into what had previously been a
politically disengaged uh population of
uh
of young white men not to say that all
of doctor who fandom is one is young
white men but that's who people like
that try to speak to but setting them
aside for a moment
at least some of these people who get
so
angry
every time anything in doctor who
suggests
that
the current system we live in has
problems
or
presents literally any character who
isn't a straight white man
and they lose their damn minds
it's a cop-out for us to say well that's
not what doctor who fandom is
that's not all that dr who fandom is
but it is part of it
and so i think for my approach to these
sorts of things in general it can be
helpful on occasion
to talk about them
but to not address them because that
invites them into the conversation
we can talk about
their ideas and why they're wrong and
why they are
harmful and hurtful and hateful but we
don't have to name them we don't have to
call them out uh specifically and i'm
not sure there's a lot of good that
comes of that we should head off their
hate at the past but we can talk about
these concepts without having to engage
with these people at all and i don't
mean like engage in an active debate
don't ever do that but like even in
terms of like uh well i'm gonna call
them out and point out how stupid they
are and not that i have a problem with
other creators who do that some creators
who i even like do that at least on
occasion but it's just not something
that i'm ever going to do because i
don't
see a ton of value in it at least versus
other things i could be doing with my
time
all right so we've got oh
got a few questions here all right
um i'll try and get through these
uh would you want to see a star trek
show set in the 29th century that
focuses on time travel more than
exploring space probably not but also
keep in mind i am not caught up even
slightly on all things star trek so
um i don't know enough about what is or
is going is or isn't going on to know
even how that would slot in or if it
would so probably not the best person to
ask do you think disney would ever allow
the leads of one of their mcu movies to
be explicitly queer and i mean like
actually give them a partner or
something not just allude to it with an
offhanded comment like they did with
loki uh ever yes
foreseeable future
no
um
i mean and part of that just has to do
with how few prominent queer
characters there are for them to even
pull from
like it if eternals had done better it
might be a different situation um but
because eternals not only underperform
financially but also critically and they
loaded like i swear to god they loaded
every single freaking um
representation egg into that damn basket
that's gonna set things back a little
bit which is unfortunate do i think
it'll ever happen sure
this year next year year after five
years no probably not
uh
let's see it ended up getting cancelled
because of shenanigans but for a while
amazon had planned to adapt the culture
novels oh okay so this is uh this is a
series of books by e m bank i've
reviewed two of them i have another one
on my docket for this year
um two questions about that if it ever
happened who would you want to play
uh lead in the player of games ah
i'm not a good person to ask for fan
casting
um
how would you depict the sex changing
would you recast characters who changed
sex or would you make them look
different with cg
um
okay
um so
someone to play the lead for player of
games um
i don't know why colin salmon's leaping
to mind
i think he's just able to do the calm
thing but you can tell there's a lot
going on behind the eyes really well
i think he'd i think he'd be good for
that uh as as for the uh the sex change
aspect of those stories i think my own
personal preference
would be to cast
two actors two similarly looking actors
one of each gender and to have them work
really close together
like
flat out learn each other's mannerisms
um
because i think the the
the way to do it wrong is to get two
different people and just have it seem
like they're two completely different
people but have them maintain similar
mannerisms outlook have them both
understand and agree
the way a character would respond and
possibly even go out of their way to
sync up uh certain aspects of patterns
of speech that's how i would do it
personally
um
so i'm on to the next question so you
know the mass shooting uh
yeah
which one the latest one which latest
one welcome to america
uh so initially i heard there was bad
news like i was watching a live stream
the streamer just said something about
bad news and i had to look up what it
was myself
is it bad that when i found that it was
quote unquote just a mass shooting i was
slightly relieved the reason i felt that
way was because i was expecting the bad
news to be something that affects
millions of people like the roe league
but instead it was just one guy killed
13 people
i don't think you're a bad person for
feeling a sense of relief at that
i think it says a lot about the state of
the world
that finding that out gave you a sense
of relief versus what you thought it was
gonna be i think that is what it
condemns
uh what big finnish audio dramas would
you recommend for start but from new who
your video on the topic mostly
recommends story from previous doctors
i'm not really sure i want to start with
unfamiliar characters
unfortunately i have not listened to
very much of the
big finish stuff with the newer doctors
i have i am in possession of but i have
not had the time to listen to ninth
doctor
adventures um i haven't listened to any
of the tenth doctor stuff
so
i'm i'm still
i understand your reasoning i'm still
going to recommend jubilee
because
story wise it's what dalek from series
one is based off of so even if you're
not super familiar with number six um
which is the doctor in that story
you'll still know enough about the story
going in that it'll help you a climate
to the audio medium if you're not used
to audio dramas
because you'll be coming into a story
that you already know at least aspects
of so you'll find your footing in
following the story way way way easier
and that'll give you a chance to focus
on getting to know the character because
you're not going to be completely
floundering with the narrative
there are probably some very good ones
with um
with some of the newer doctors
i mean
some stuff that is fun here here's
another one i'll recommend something
that is very fun
um and might give you a taste uh try
missy series one
i had a lot of fun with that and unless
you just flat out don't like missy in
which case probably best not to i think
that's a solid one like again to kind of
get your feet under you
uh what did i think about the revelation
of king's origin okay so we're back to
owl house i really liked it because
uh he got what he originally wanted to
see this than one rather than what he
wants now
uh i thought it was sweet i also like
flashbacks to baby king is like the
cutest freaking thing ever
all right all right i'm almost done with
these and then i'll come back to the
chat
spent more time in the discord than i
usually do on the subject of the doctor
would you say the doctor works best
um as this
uh king of
as this kind of ash williams evil dead
style survivor
such as the doctor began as more or less
just an average if eccentric time lord
who left gallifrey and went from
essentially a nobody
to something important rather than being
this destined to be great idea i don't
have a problem with epic destinies but
the doctors always felt off i actually
don't like either
for the doctor because as far as i'm
concerned and i've said this in videos
before
i don't think the doctor should be
important
on a galactic or universal scale and
people will try and argue with me on
that it's like but the doctor is
traveling through all of time and space
so like he's
he she or they are showing up all over
the place so of course they're embedded
in in history and are important
everywhere no do you know how big the
universe is do you know how long time
expands to
do you know how old the doctor is
confirmed because you can't count the
billions of years that he supposedly
spent in the freaking
[Music]
confession dial from heaven sent he's
around two thousand years old
i'm sorry
two thousand years of life you do not
embed yourself across
all this light years of space and these
billions and trillions of years of time
so i hate the idea of the doctor being
important at all i double hate it as a
destiny idea which is part of why i
deeply
deeply load the timeless child i don't
care about lore
some people hate that because it messes
up lore i don't care about lore i do
care about the doctor just being someone
who shows up and wants to help that's
all i want the doctor to be
i do want the doctor to be the smartest
person in the room i do want the doctor
to come in and save people but not
because that's some destiny or some
praise here like no just
well
something's wrong i'm gonna try and help
that's all i want
hey anyways
i'm back in the chat
um
oh got some more super chats so i got to
deal with those
whoo let's see supreme omega in 2000's
comics how do you feel about writers and
editors recreating their nostalgia with
hal and barry revived in dc and peter
being single again in marvel some of the
worst stuff that happened in comics in
the last 40 years that's what i think
uh i i actually i
i hate those decisions
as much as we love to mock the 90s in
comics
um
boy oh boy
at least that's
silly
the things that comics had to do to
bring back hal
and bear and like i am
i'm more annoyed with dc than marvel
although dissolving peter's marriage was
really freaking stupid
but um
with
the stuff that dc was doing
it robbed them of one of the things they
had that marvel didn't really do
legacy heroes
and i loved the idea of legacy heroes
but jeff johns and dan dadio decided
well
ditches into flash that i grew up with i
grew up barry allen so wally west you
don't exist
it's
selfish and it's short-sighted and it
robbed the dc
comics of one of its better attributes
the entire idea of legacy was something
that was increasingly becoming embedded
and was really cool mantle's being
passed on who's worthy this new person
who takes on the mantle are they falling
short does should someone else step up
it brings a whole new aspect of
storytelling that they were just
starting to get into and they just
freaking threw it out the window
i'm like i
i always liked marvel better
but
even to the degree that i like dc
it only makes me more
ticked off at them for what they've what
they've spent the last 20 odd years
doing
if i here's the thing if i liked dc
comics any more than i do it would only
make me hate them more
if that makes sense
uh
do you think big finish will be able to
redeem uh
doctor and future stories i think they
will be able to offer her better stories
than she's had if that's what you mean
by redemption
dude
the 90s were totally like that man
yeah they were
yep to paraphrase the doctor's just this
guy you know
yes he is thank you oh
damn
i was going to say that was oolong
kalufit it's not
i don't think
uh
damn it
i thought i was gonna show off my
hitchhiker's guide knowledge by
remembering who the heck actually said
that i know who it is it's zaphod shrink
but i cannot remember his
name now
nuts
i disagree with your viewpoints on
multiverse i personally find them an
opening to endless uh
to endless stories like
i get that in theory but the thing is in
my mind at least in terms of um
the practicality of it
multiverses are usually used to actually
just tell the same stories again with a
twist
because now it's like ooh
it's batman again but this time he's
russian it's batman again but this time
he's a vampire like in my mind a
multiverse should be
something more than parallel
you know what i should revise that i
don't have a problem with multiverse i
am deeply bored by parallel worlds
though
deeply bored like what a boring idea you
couldn't think of anything interesting
to do you had to create a whole new
world to do the same boring stuff you're
already doing in
and again it has more to do with how
rarely i've seen them pay off in
anything that was good for more than one
or two stories
captain omni uh thank you very much
again so the doctor should just be known
by the dalek cybermen since common
villains and the rest being who's this i
actually love that idea yeah basically
like occasionally like the time lords
he shouldn't the the i'm saying he
because that's who we're getting now but
i'll go with they because we've had
multi-genders the doctor they should not
they should be known by the time lords
they shouldn't be important to the time
lords they should know who the doctor is
because
the doctor's annoying
but the doctor shouldn't be important to
the time lords the doctor should be
important definitely to the daleks they
freaking hate him and
sometimes the cybermen i wouldn't even
say that should always be the case
but barring that only a handful of
specific people like obviously the
master cares
oh my god if they ever finally bring him
back he should care but by and large
yeah the general response is
i'm the doctor
who i mean that's the name of the show
doctor who
nobody knows not because he's ancient
and mysterious but like
who's this guy
shane
uh wear a stick
we're rustic
uh something i butchered it i'm sure
thank you so much for the super chat i
always like the idea of what made the
doctor special is that they chose to
leave stodgy uptight people and help the
inhaler and
help and experience the universe yes yes
exactly that
sorry but could you repeat the name of
the uh player of games actor you
suggested i googled what i thought you
said and got nothing a colin salmon
uh was who i thought
uh salmon as in the fish i believe now
you've got me second guessing it
yeah colin salmon last name uh
s-a-l-m-o-n
that's who i would go with
i was into comics in the 80s x-men new
mutants elfquest i was into comics in
the 90s
for a little bit
but then the 90s really got going and i
had to bail
gag hellfront thank you rowan i knew
somebody would get me that would would
have my back for that
um
i should wrap it up soon but i feel like
i spent so long in the uh
in the discord i'm just gonna try and
catch up a little bit
his favorite family guy character i
haven't watched family guy in ages
i don't even know
um
i love the series sliders and that
premise depended majorly on multiverse i
liked sliders at the time i think i'd
probably be bored by it if i tried
watching it now
i missed a couple of super chats oh
thank you carowind jeez
oh you're right you're right i did
thank you so much carowind that's my bad
that is my bad
everybody thank heroin for
wrangling my squirrel brain she's very
good at it
um
uh rya c
raya orreya i'm not sure um
thank you so much i recently became a
patron this is my first live stream i
think you critique doctor who episodes
really well give plenty of pros and cons
thank you
thank you so much
it's wonderful to have you here
and john finals came in with another one
can the doctor be read as an anarchist
hero who defies the power structures of
the universe
sometimes i think that's definitely an
approach to take with the doctor
um and like people should understand uh
this would be a case where you need to
understand anarchism
as a political philosophy not just the
general idea of
anarchy
like
anarchism is an actual political
philosophy that basically says power
structures are inherently
immoral um
[Music]
is the super condensed version of it so
anything that distributes power as
evenly as possible that is what they
want but it's not socialism it's not
where you are purposefully dividing
everything up
um equally because that itself is a
power system and a power structure that
forces the divide and they they're
against that too
i do think the doctor
frequently
is uh
has um
anarchistic tendencies let's go with
that
let's see where was i
oh
well welsh wrestling geeks
i love that thank you so much for the
super chat i always found that jackie as
a character is held in higher regard
with uk fans because in the uk everyone
knows a jackie that that makes sense
i don't particularly care for jackie
but i don't know a jackie so yeah know
that that actually that that's probably
the single best explanation i've ever
gotten for the appeal of jackie
you did it in one sentence
people have been telling me for years
why they like jackie and you got me to
understand it better in one sentence
than anybody else
nice
uh captain omni again came back thanks
so much my favorite take on the
multiverse is one that might seem like
just parallel worlds but it goes in
wildly different areas
i mean like that's the general thing for
me a multiverse
and and this is something that like
the doctor strange movie
did in tiny doses but mostly was doing
the parallel universe thing like
it should really be
something
so and like here's the thing that's
really weird to me about when you're
doing the parallel worlds thing
the points of divergence are always
recent
and it's never
they almost never do something where the
world is completely different because of
one tiny detail that was changed from 3
000 years ago
it's always like well basically the
world was exactly as we experienced up
up until about 10 years ago and then
there was this divergent thing that gave
us this alternate
universe i'm like that's that's real
boring like
and like here's me saying up front i
think to make to take proper advantage
of a multiverse concept
is a lot of work like to the point that
i get why people don't do it that way
except it's the only way to make it
interesting to me at least at this point
and let's see here darren voss just
confirmed jacqueline king is back as
sylvia
sylvia sylvia
um
give me a second
jacqueline
king
oh
oh donna's mother
okay
that's not super surprising
that's not something i need to make
another video on
that's that's
hmm
oh
do you think big finish could write
better stories in the future to help uh
doc jodie whittaker's doctor shine i
hope so
i think they could we'll
see um was zephod responsible for the
earth getting demolished in the books
um
no
no he wasn't
i'm assuming you've only seen the movies
or at least are more familiar with the
movie than the books
no the earth
so
the reason the earth got destroyed
changed a couple of times from book to
book
i don't think it was ever zaphod's fault
if i'm remembering correctly
anarchism is a branch of socialism it is
but it's it's a far end of it
like people people think that socialism
is as far as leftist ideal ideology goes
like
nope it uh it keeps going
wait have you seen edge of the world
labyrinth runners and oh titanware art
thou i was under the impression that
you'd only seen up to hollow mind and
other episodes on disney plus i don't
think i've seen those
uh alyssa
uh would you refer to jackie tyler as a
carrot jack he's not a karen
sylvia might be jackie isn't
no
absolutely not
but yeah i should i should wrap it up
um
so uh
255 a.d my point with anarchism is was
not that it is anti-socialist it's that
your your app your actual anarchist
would consider even socialism to be a
power structure it would probably be one
that they would think is better
and
less an immediate need of dismantlement
than
anything further right of it
but most anarchists would also seek to
dismantle a socialist power structure
just maybe not with quite as much fervor
ah sneaking in
one oh someone was asking about jelly
babies yeah somebody sent me jelly
babies once
they're weird
they're weird
i don't hate them but yeah they're weird
a captain omni
thank you so much one more time earth 13
in dc is a fun alternate earth where
magic literally took over all aspects
like constantine as the tights weary
superhero called hellblazer now see
that's a little bit more interesting
than the usual stuff but even that i
suspect i'd only find entertaining for
um
for one
outing i think jackie's too poor to be a
karen
i would say that karen tendencies skew
middle class
it's not an absolute requirement though
i have met some
um
some poverty line karen's
and they're not jackie
so that's another thing that i feel
confident saying that jackie is not a
karen
uh
anyways
yes okay uh
[Music]
the twitch
uh the twitch i alyssa i don't know
because i don't remember the names of
the episodes
i don't i i don't in specific uh
maybe if you're talking about where
somebody asked about king it's possible
that like i was thinking about uh the
earlier
uh episode about king's background if
there's a newer one that i haven't seen
that i might have conflated the one i
have with one that i haven't yet and
didn't catch the thing with the question
i don't remember the uh
the the episode names anyways i'm gonna
wrap it up yes twitch in the morning 10
30 uh a.m eastern time i am continuing
to play transistor which is a cool game
i'm enjoying that so i'm going to stick
with that at the very least
um throughout the remainder of this week
so i hope that um folks will tune in for
that
uh hopefully i will also have uh the
witch finders ready to go live tomorrow
as well
um on the main channel
and i gotta i gotta get editing done for
something to go up in the break room
because it's been almost a week since
something went there
yes i have no free time did i mention
that i think i mentioned that anyways
thank you all for tuning in and being
here with me i appreciate
um
your time
and
your support
so i hope that
you be well
be safe
be kind and high voltage sneaking in
under the wire bloody uk time zones i
always miss your live streams well thank
you very much for the super chat all the
same
just remember that you are the council
you are beautiful you are valid you are
loved
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
my cavity